vamos ahora a hablar de salud en directo
américa de france 24 más romero sala ya
está lista conmigo en el estudio mar
feliz inicio de semana feliz mañana el
lunes vamos a hablar entonces de las
campañas de vacunación contra el kobe 19
que ya como se pasa el tiempo es rápido
cumplen un año mar sin embargo la
investigación todavía avanza y le
pregunta entonces qué nos espera en el
futuro si cumplen un año incluso más de
un año de hecho porque soy yo se
empezaron en diciembre ahora que pienso
de 2020 entonces pues teniendo en cuenta
todo ese tiempo que ha pasado siempre es
bueno repasar en que sigue también la
investigación científica por ejemplo la
organización mundial de la salud es
sigue aprobando candidatos vacunales la
última fue novavax ahorita lo hablaremos
con más profundidad y también pues
recordemos que la variante omicron y la
llegada de la variante omicron a
nuestras vidas ha hecho que las
investigaciones se refuercen buscando
unos candidatos vacunales que sean algo
más flexibles contra las variantes de 19
para hablar de todo esto y mucho más
estamos con el doctor carlos de eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia doctor
muy buenos días gracias por acompañarnos
un lunes más lo inicio de más estábamos
hablando de nueva vacuna vacuna que ya
ha recibido por ejemplo la aprobación de
la organización mundial de la salud y
también de reino unido que sabemos de
esta vacuna y qué ventajas puede ofrecer
su aprobación
marc es una buena noticia que se haya
aprobado esta vacuna eso se hizo en
estos meses y es tener un intento en
nuestra árbol de argumentos para luchar
contra el coronario es una nueva vacuna
esta es una una que se sintetiza a
partir de proteínas es distinta de las
vacunas de rené mensajero y adenovirus y
esta vacuna viene a complementar las
otras vacunas es útil y se puede colocar
en pacientes inmunosuprimidos aún
solamente los estudios están aprobados
en población adulta pero hace parte de
toda esta indumentaria que necesitamos
para poder postular el coronavirus
idénticamente editamos esta y otras
vacunas que se están desarrollando en un
futuro doctor félix lunes feliz mañana y
le pregunta entonces que otros
candidatos vacunales deberíamos seguir
de cerca
pero lo primero es que las vacunas
tienen que ser producidas masivamente
tenemos que tener disponibilidad
recordemos que el coronario no va a ser
de un año dos años va a ser por lo menos
una década y vamos a necesitar que estas
vacunas se produzcan incluso localmente
en la región y que hayan plataformas
distintas ya tenemos virus inactivos rn
a adenovirus ahora está en proteínas
pero evitamos más opciones más vacunas
liberar las potentes las patentes para
que se puedan producir en la región y
que sean disponibles para todo el mundo
incluyendo la población pediátrica
población de uno suprimido y población
restante claro de hecho en ese sentido
le iba a hacer la siguiente pregunta y
es que en sudáfrica en uno de los
centros de desarrollo vacuna les
lograron desarrollar una parte no dar
los primeros pasos hacia una vacuna
utilizando la tecnología de adn
mensajero que recordemos es la de
moderna o la the fighter sin tener
acceso a las patentes a la información
de estas farmacéuticas es posible que
pudieran llegar a desarrollar un fármaco
propio
sigue sin duda es posible porque la
tecnología se le venía mensajero y
conociéndose el vídeo se puede plantear
desarrollar las vacunas es tener la
tecnología pero obviamente se ahorrarían
muchos estos pasos si ya dando un paso
de solidaridad entre nosotros liberamos
las patentes por parte de algunas
farmacéuticas para que se puedan
desarrollar este tipo de vacunas
recordemos que estas vacunas tienen que
ese es un acto de solidaridad mundial y
nonato negocios no se pueden manejar por
leyes del mercado porque mientras haya
población que no pueda acceder a vacunas
por su costo pues va a haber la
probabilidad que se desarrollan nuevas
variantes y que estas vacunas sean
ineficaces creo que es un paso que da a
sudáfrica pero es un paso que queríamos
dar mundialmente al tener acceso a la
tecnología para desarrollar este tipo de
vacunas ahora actor pero entonces como
se pueden crear vacunas que duren más
tiempo y que protejan contra más
variantes
obviamente esta es la primera generación
de las vacunas necesitamos una
generación ya se está diseñando una
segunda generación de vacunas en donde
vamos a entender un poco más como en la
respuesta inmunológica pero además de
eso en que personas dura más y dura
menos la vacuna porque definitivamente
la población mayor la población
inmunosuprimidas duran menos el efecto
vacunal que la población pediátrica o
adolescente entonces en esta segunda
generación de hormonas vamos a entender
más si la vacuna es cada cuánto y en qué
personas se dan la periodicidad todo lo
hacemos universalmente pero seguramente
en un futuro vamos a poderlo segmentar
mucho mejor otra de las investigaciones
que avanza es las vacunas nasales hemos
visto que se estaban desarrollando
también algunos candidatos que hay
experimentos que ya demuestran que
funcionan en animales que sabemos de
este tipo de vacunas cómo funcionan y
pueden ser el futuro de la inmunización
contra el kobe 19
esto hace parte de ese arsenal de las
nuevas vacunas que hablábamos estas
vacunas han sido para reforzar la
inmunidad que se hace en las mucosas uno
de los problemas que tenemos es que no
se corta la cadena de transmisión es
decir estas vacunas previenen la
enfermedad grave la hospitalización pero
no impiden que nosotros nos infecte moss
de una persona que posee coronarios al
hacer una vacuna local en un spray nasal
permitiría un refuerzo para impedir esa
cadena de transmisión eso es muy
interesante pero además de eso es una
podría ser un refuerzo natural a las
vacunas que ya tenemos intramuscular es
entonces son buenas noticias y esperemos
que se sigan desarrollando en un futuro
doctor muchísimas gracias entonces por
la información también más romeros a la
yo los despido vamos a pasar con nuestra
segunda mitad del día para hablar del
amor